bei einem schweren busunglück auf der a
24 mecklenburg vorpommern werden 31
personen verletzt drei von ihnen schwer
am frühen samstagmorgen gegen 6 uhr
passiert das unglück
der fanbus fährt geradeaus berliner
richtung hamburg als er plötzlich von
der fahrbahn abkommt das tonnenschwere
fahrzeug fährt in den graben und kippte
auf die seite
die bergung der verletzten stellt sich
für die einsatzkräfte als schwierig
heraus eine schwierigkeit ist sie in die
busse kommen auch und sich eine lage zu
verschaffen wir haben hier beteiligt
durch fünf feuerwehren bus die
berufsfeuerwehr familien ein
hubschrauber im einsatz
mehrere rtw ist also ein manuskript auch
die scheiben auf dem dach des busses
eingeschlagen eine leiter führt zum
inneren des fahrzeuges verletzten
insassen kommen sofort in umliegende
krankenhäuser die polizei ermittelt zur
zeit die unfallursache mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren